[Music]
hey everybody its charlie everyone's
freaking out about the Avengers 4
trailer I got a lot of questions about
this clip that's supposedly
quote-unquote leaked the other day so
I'll explain what's going on with this
there's a special infinity war event
tonight and everybody was just expecting
them to drop a trailer today there
actually is a plan that Marvel in the
Russos have so we'll break it down we're
doing a new round of that IMAX ticket
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave an Avengers
related comment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this couple big
things right up front I think that clip
is 100% fake mostly because of the
actual clips that it included and the
way that Marvel promotes its upcoming
trailer releases there's something weird
that happens when people are waiting for
a big trailer to drop and then potato
footage drops on a youtube channel with
no subscribers people make the mistake
of just assuming that it's a real League
but there are a lot of channels that do
nothing but just make fake trailers like
this so what it is is it's a clip of red
skull on Vermeer from infinity war then
there's a clip of Ant Man from ant-man
the wasp in his new costume looking down
from Hank Pimm's new lab the little tag
says trailer coming tomorrow
yes Marvel does do trailer teasers like
that but the reason why everyone was
expecting a trailer to drop today is
because it's the one-year anniversary of
them dropping the first Avengers
infinity war trailer there's also a
special infinity war screening that the
Russos are doing tonight you probably
saw people all over your timelines
speculating about a trailer dropping
today but it is way too late in the day
for a trailer to actually drop as I'm
posting this video the way they're
handling the Avengers 4 trailer is a
little bit different from what they've
done in previous years typically what
they'll do is they'll just give a bunch
of footage to a trailer company that
does nothing but cut professional
trailers for big media companies like
Disney Fox all the other people that
release giant tentpole movies they make
a couple different edits Disney decides
which one it likes and then they'll drop
that one everywhere what happened when
we got to infinity war last year is if
the Russo started to take a bigger hand
in picking how they were going to market
the film just because they were trying
to avoid spoilers you have all that fake
Hulk stuff they went above and beyond to
try and promote a movie with the event
in it without actually telling you what
the plot of the movie was which is
actually pretty hard to do they had to
spend a couple million dollars to make
that fake CG hook look real just for a
couple seconds in a trailer that they
never intended on putting in the movie
the Monday before they dropped that the
Russos posted this cryptic three to
their Instagram and social accounts it
looked like no other posts they'd ever
made so people assumed that something
weird was happening then that Tuesday
they dropped a 2 so people are like holy
crap they're counting down we're
probably gonna get the trailer sure
enough a little while after that Good
Morning America posted on their Twitter
feed trailer coming tomorrow and boom
they dropped the infinity war trailer at
around 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning
eastern time just because Good Morning
America airs really early in the morning
so typically Disney does stuff like that
when they released really big trailers
thus far the only thing that the Russos
have been posting on their social
account recently was trying to promote
the bar that one of the Russos bought
like he wanted to get people to get
excited about it so he did a QA for
Avengers 4 at the bar while they were
being served drinks they also visited
the set of the Mandalorian that Jon
Favreau is overseeing he's the
showrunner for that TV show Taika
Waititi who directed thor ragnarok is
directing the season finale so they were
visiting him on set while they were
shooting the season finale of that
Mandalorian TV series if you're really
excited about that don't worry we'll get
a trailer for that at the next Star Wars
Celebration or d23 something like that
they tend to save Star Wars trailers for
big Star Wars events but that's all the
Russos have been doing lately Kevin
Feige himself confirmed that they would
post the trailer before the end of the
year so obviously there are only a
certain number of weeks that they could
wait to drop that that's why everyone
thinks that it's going to be dropping
next week because Disney has dropped a
really big trailer every couple of days
for the last couple of weeks we got that
Lion King trailer at Thanksgiving last
week then a couple days after that we
got the Artemis Fowl trailer at midnight
which is just a weird time to drop a
trailer for a Disney especially a
children's movie not that many children
are gonna be awake at midnight but they
tend to wait a couple days between big
trailer releases and because Avengers 4
is so big and Marvel does a really good
job trying to build hype and gain extra
attention on the day that it drops
trailers right now it just seems like
they're going to
wait till next week in a couple days
before that happens the Roses will just
start trolling people again on their
social media account so you know that
something is coming up but as for exact
day it could be any time I'm just
expecting it to drop in the morning at a
reasonable hour during the week it's not
gonna be like in the middle of the night
on a weekend or anything like that as
for leaks and stuff like that you know
who knows there could be a leak in the
next couple of days last year was a
little bit different we had gotten a
little bit of infinity war footage at
Comic Con but Marvel skipped Comic Con
this year then there was a really weird
person called the ascended ancient that
leaked a couple of unfinished scenes
like whole scenes that just didn't have
special effects late into it if you're
not sure whether footage is a real leak
or not this is an example of what a real
leak was
they stop reality stone no
I told you I sold it
I imagine it's like breathing for you so
you do understand
and you would surrender something so
precious I didn't know what it was and
you are the fool that I took you for
and so last chance Charlotte where's the
stone today he pays for the deaths of my
wife and daughter
so notice how everything seems like it's
super polished there's just no special
effects like someone just joint it right
off of one of the visual effects artists
hard drives that is a legit leak the
clip that I put at the beginning of this
seems like more of a fan edit made it to
look like a leak just in the way that it
was posted and recorded using a potato
on a TV which is a valiant effort but
still super fake for those of you asking
about red skull during Avengers 4 the
Ross mark hand was actually talking
about that remember Ross Mark and Erin
from The Walking Dead is now playing the
red skull in the MCU wherever Marvel
might decide to use them again the funny
thing too is is that when they shot
infinity war they were also shooting
their Avengers for scenes so when the
actors say they don't know what the cut
of Avengers 4 is going to be it's
because they shot everything all at the
same time so they legit did not know
when they were filming a scene whether
it was supposed to be a scene for
infinity war or Avengers 4 there were
only three real infinity war scripts on
the set of both of those movies and the
ruses had most of those copies in their
possession the whole time
the only other actors that got to see
the entire script were Benedict
Cumberbatch because you know he had the
secret plan it was a bit of a feint and
he's gonna be a big deal during Avengers
4 in probably Robert Downey jr. because
there were a lot of setups during
infinity war that they had to pay off so
a lot of the actors just needed to know
where things were going particularly
Benedict Cumberbatch but like I said
there's that special infinity war event
that the ruses are doing tonight
whatever secrets they reveal I will
totally make a video about tomorrow no
worries
leave your Marvel video requests in the
comments below
congratulations Ryan Scholes you're the
giveaway winner for my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my non-spoilery
spider-man into the spider-verse review
and click here for my brand new Thor
Stormbreaker deleted scene video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]